so let's think about something a little
bit what do you think 17 divided by 2 is
going to be well you might immediately
realize that it's not obvious what you
need to multiply 2 by in order to get to
17 there's no whole number that I could
put here that gets us to 17 we know that
2 times let's see 2 times 8 is a little
bit less than that 2 times 8 is equal to
16 and we know that 2 times 9 is going
to be a little bit more than that is
equal to 18 and so this question mark 2
times question mark is equal to 17 this
helps us know that our question mark our
unknown value here is going to be
between 8 & 9 it is going to be 8 point
something so let's do another example if
someone were to ask you hey let's think
about 18 divided by 4 and you don't have
to figure out exactly what it is just
yet but I want you to think about what
two consecutive whole numbers is 18
divided by 4 whatever that is what is
that between well we could do something
similar we could say all right let's see
4 times 4 is equal to 16 so that doesn't
quite get us to 18 we could say that 4
times 5 is equal to 20 so that's more
than 18 so 4 times question mark is
equal to 18 this helps us realize that
because 18 is between 16 and 20 this
question mark right over here is going
to be between 4 & 5 so 18 divided by 4
is going to be 4 point something
now another way of thinking about or
estimating what division might result in
is through an inequality so if I were to
say 87 divided by 9 how would you
compare that to 10 over here so there's
a couple of ways you could compare it
you could say maybe this is greater than
10 maybe it's equal to 10
maybe it is less than ten so pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
what would you put here is it less than
greater than or equal to ten well we
know it's not equal to ten we know that
ninety divided by nine is equal to ten
and let's see if we go one multiple of
nine less than that we know that 81
divided by nine is equal to nine and so
87 divided by nine is in between these
two values let me do this in another
color so 87 divided by nine is going to
be something in between nine and ten and
so it is going to be less than ten so
the whole point of this video is start
to get us a little bit comfortable with
this idea of dividing where we might get
an answer that is not a whole number and
in the future we'll learn how to compute
that but for now we're just learning to
estimate and just get a sense of hey
okay this is going to be between eight
and nine this is going to be between
four and five this is going to be
between nine and ten which just means
it's going to be nine point something
which means it's going to be less than
ten